it's April in the backcountry of Montana
all season extreme skiers Michael Nugent
and Nick Baldwin have been tempting fate
scheme is rugged and remote terrain far
from the area's designated ski run so
far they've managed to stay out of
danger but thanks to a deep blanket of
fresh snow that's about to change
watch as Mike tackles this mountain the
snowpack cracks beneath them then chases
him downhill
we'll show you again the snow bears down
from behind Mike tries to outrace it
[Music]
but he's completely overtaken and
heading straight into the tree
Mike's been swamped by a force strong
enough to flatten our house amazingly he
survives
although left with a broken hip and
thighs if it worked for a tree he might
not have made it it broke his fall and
kept him from being suffocated